if you have headphones we could plug
yours into I only have Bluetooth ones
[Music]
what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
what's your name
I'm Erin Alexander Erin Alexander have
you hanging seen the chapel roosterteeth
no don't don't
yeah you can mock me so this is a
heavily requested reaction so late to do
it this is from 2015 this video damn I'm
sure you guys have heard of it pastor
and if you've seen it
fortunately he hasn't either red vs.
blue from roosterteeth season 1 episode
1 why are we here I've never seen this
show neither have I knows a lot of hype
behind it of course I played halo but I
don't know what exactly this is I know
what halo is halo is the thing Jesus has
[Laughter]
[Music]
just come out 2015
[Music]
[Music]
see if I remember all these names yeah I
was thinking I rose no look so like yeah
caboose I know those are you two burgers
[Music]
Lopez I see you George
[Music]
why don't they do this in front of every
acquisition
[Music]
there's no way to scan
very
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Wow
that's great that was to watch the
second one I'm down like you really get
a vibe here good I really gonna watch
the first one let's see how this good
season 1 episode T red gets a delivery
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay dude great hangout
he definitely is chill with a friend eat
some salad and just watch I don't know
how to describe it I mean yeah it's in
the halo world but it's like what's the
downtime like it's like workplace comedy
of Halo
yeah yeah oh wow you're good I'm glad
you're here you know what it kinda
reminds I would have spent 20 minutes
looking for that perfect sentence to say
it kind of reminded me of I know this
came out before but the end of the
spoilers for mandalorian the Tycho OTT
episode with the - yeah that's a great
call yeah I mean I thought the jokes are
frickin hilarious and like the
characters themselves it's a great
balance okay maybe it's one of those
like weird animated shows where they're
having like existential conversations or
something there are setups that they
have is like one person's kind of like
just straight shooter smart straight man
and they got one who's a lot on the
weaker side and it's like on both camps
but even this I don't know Colonel
general but also be constructing some of
this like hallo world by putting it in
the workplace setting yeah and like what
are they doing when they're not fighting
each other like how boring of a life
must it be yeah
a little confused because like I've
never really played the Halo games I'm
what do they have Pumas i love halo this
is such a blast
I've never played like the storylines of
them you know I playing online with my
buddies all the time it's like it's one
of my favorite pastimes hello it's mo
you know what I really realized while
watching this was that even though the
animation is so simple and feels like
some like mid to early two-thousands
like ps2 ps1 kind of graphics it's
really the writing that makes it's so
hilarious
of course because they can't really move
a lot so it's just purely based on
dialogue there's so much you can do with
just characters words in their very
inner plays well I had to second-guess
it when I was first watching it cuz I
was like wait a minute
did they just record them playing like
they all logged in and they record them
playing but then I was examining certain
shots and I realized no they had to
animate this [ __ ] didn't they yeah they
got great animators for it because it
had me confused for a split second
because I thought maybe they've just
recorded the gameplay and then they
dubbed over it and they just like
directed while they were playing it but
then like there are certain shots in
here we're like oh wait there's no way
else but that is just from the game like
they they had to have animated it and
it's they did a great job on bringing
that to life
yeah you know and making it feel lived
in within there
yeah this is some hilarious stuff I'm
glad to finally watch this knowing I'd
have to watch more I would come over
every week now but just to watch more
red vs. blue alright guys well thanks
for watching and subscribe to
roosterteeth if you haven't done so
already they actually said I didn't I
didn't wear the proper shirt they sent
me over some birds of prey gear they're
gonna hate you
I know subscribe to the rejects click
that notification bell follow Aaron on
the social media last but not least
patron of the day Shia today goes to Zac
fifl and the reason I want to shout out
Zac specifically is out of everyone
who's been encouraging me to go check
this show out undoubtedly
it's been Zac he knows it I don't need
to say any more about it
alright the guy sure is an interesting
fella in the gaming writing books for
fun yada yada yada but Zack is for sure
the number one person in my life who has
pushed me to go watching this series
that's something I've always been
interested in but I need that extra
little nudge so thank you sac for being
you and whenever I hear the name Zack I
think of two things a really really
really really good-looking guy I don't
know one ugly Zack I think I'm really
really good looking guys backed up by
the second thing being they're probably
a really cocky douchebag I'm gonna
assume you're only one and not two okay
let's be safe out there